deux agences de crédit moody's et
standard and poor's accordent déjà au
québec une meilleure note
car l'ontario fitch accorde la même note
double à moins dans le cas de fitch dont
québec et ontario
dbrs était la seule à donner une
meilleure note à l'ontario mais cette
note est désormais là même la province
qu'à la meilleure note
c'est la colombie britannique triple a
dans presque tous les cas dbrs à sa
deuxième meilleure note pour la
colombie-britannique sébastien lavoie et
économiste en chef à la banque
laurentienne notre invité ce soit pour
parler bien sûr de la notation du québec
bonsoir en soi risque ça signale que
cette hausse de notation pour le
gouvernement du québec a sauvé avec la
tête du québec le gouvernement 15 mai
des obligations c'est de très bonne
qualité
donc ça change la perception ou les
investisseurs avant dans le fond le
québec était pas être un bon élève dans
un groupe moyen est là aujourd'hui on
dit que l'élève change dans un groupe
supérieur 5 le meilleur qui ait la
colombie-britannique mais pourtant on
entend souvent que le québec est
endettée puis même le gouvernement le
répète cela que le gouvernement que le
québec est endetté que le niveau
d'endettement et d'intérêts à payer
reste élevé oui c'est vrai on dépense
environ 25 millions au service de la
dette chaque jour c'est quand même pas
rien mais on a fait des progrès continus
justement qu'on aurait dû la dette
un des points principaux qui a été
mentionné aujourd'hui par guyot reste
également la saine gestion des finances
publiques est ce que ça veut dire
je pense que c'est une continuité du
gouvernement actuel de porsche et sur ce
qui avait été lancée en 2014 en 2014 qui
a été fait sous l'ancien gouvernement
libéral de dire mais voici les revenus
que j'ai qu'est ce que je peux
maintenant faire comme dépenses et
offrir des services et des programmes à
la population on continue avec cette
mentalité là ce qui vient exprès en
partie je crois la décision
d'aujourd'hui mais est-ce que la hausse
de notation est attribuable au travail
de carlos leitao je veux dire
franchement au cours de ces quatre
années où il a mené des politiques de
rigueur ou d'austérité qui ont été
dénoncés d'eux ne part mais en même
temps les
notation salue et cela c'est vrai lot 2
ans lebel avait été lancée par l'agencé
mp on s'en rappelle en juin 2017 et
aujourd'hui dans le fond on reconnaît
que le grand dam actuel fait quand même
une part du travail qu'on parle de
politique pro croissance il faut
retourner au budget 2010 9 le premier
budget de la caq où on me lançait des
éléments comme retenir les travailleurs
d'expérience la francisation pour et
l'éducation pour aider le potentiel de
croissance de l'économie
le capital d'actions qu'on a mis dans un
investissement québec pour leur capital
de risque pardon a évidemment pour non
seulement donner une chance aux
nouvelles entreprises de naître mais de
d'avoir un succès donc ça c'est c'est
comme une plante on la nourrit elle
grandit et société reconnue aujourd'hui
par des bailleurs cela dit est ce que le
québec ne profite pas essentiellement
que de la bonne tenue de l'économie et
que ça va ralentir essentiellement
pourquoi on augmente la note de crédit
parce que l'économie va bien c'est vrai
en fait le débit earth avait déjà noté
l'été dernier qu'elle envisageait aussi
la note de crédit au printemps 2020 mais
le contenu de l'économie qui est très
très très favorable voire exceptionnel
et qui surplus engendrés sont non
seulement gros mais ont déjà été même
gargantuesque ben on n'attend pas au
printemps 2001 ne sommes pas capables de
les maintenir mon va se jeter comme les
autres agences et avoir une note
comparable doublera donc s'il ya un
ralentissement aux récessions le québec
une situation au niveau des finances
publiques qui très enviable par rapport
à beaucoup d'autres gouvernements
c'est certain parce qu'on a réduit le
poids de la dette ce que les autres
provinces n'ont pas réussi à faire dans
mier décor c'était normal compte tenu de
la force de l'élan économique de générer
des surplus de se refaire un peu au
niveau de son état financier pour faire
face à des jours poussant l'ontario n'a
pas sa chance
est ce que les coûts d'emprunt vont
nécessairement baisser parce qu'on
augmente la note de crédit de 2000 le
sont déjà aujourd'hui le québec peut
emprunter une obligation
d'une chance de 10 ans environ 2,5 ha
oui même 30 ans à moins de 2 à une li %
2 50% à ce qui est phénoménal
donc c'est un coût de financement qui
est inférieur à l'ontario se reflète un
peu les notes de crédit d'ailleurs du
québec
mais mêmes on se rapproche de la
colombie britannique et le cas non plus
tonique c'est quand même le meilleur
élève de la classe en quelque sorte
donc ce serait difficile de demander
plus en terme de coût de financement du
québec sont extrèmement bas
relativement parle est ce que note de
crédit plus élevées ou qui augmente
comme ça stimule la croissance
économique
je pense pas que la note changer une
grande chose que le travail avait déjà
été fait ou la perception avait déjà
changé contenu soit que les autres
agences de crédit avait déjà emboîté le
pas donc aujourd'hui c'est les nachi les
investisseurs est ce que des entreprises
qui se disaient voilà je m'en vais là
parce qu'au québec les hauts salaires de
très bien passé ça a été un des
ingrédients qui explique la performance
économique du québec actuellement le
mettre la maison en ordre
2014 2015 oui les moteurs deutz idaho
effectivement je pense qu'on était
repris à la gauche et à droite
il se désole ça fonctionne après ensuite
les capitaux arrive entendent
investissements créent des emplois dans
les nouvelles économies donc à ce qui se
passe est vraiment exceptionnel est ce
qu'il ya des risques des risques
importants l'agencé de notation ont
décrit quelques heures les tensions
commerciales par exemple parce que des
risques sur les perspectives du québec
c'est évident on va voir ce qui se passe
plutôt un plus tard pardon ce mois ci
entre les etats-unis et la chine
concernant un potentiel accord partiel
sur leur commerce à meyer toujours
l'option des marchés désir baisse que
j'ai pas pris un peu trop de risques
donc revoir le prix du riz ça quelque
part ça pourrait essentiellement mené
des coûts de financement plus élevés
pour les grandes mains pour les
corporations donc et plusieurs encore
poches de vulnérabilité je vous dirai
aux nouveaux l'économie mondiale à vous
il ya toujours des risques mais quand
judiciaire l'important ce qu'on a réussi
à
améliorer la santé des finances
publiques du québec aaa avant le
prochain
merci beaucoup sébastien lavoie plaisir
cette analyse ce soir merci